- We're here with the stars
of the new movie, "Queenpins",
Kirby Howell-Baptiste and Kristen Bell!
Give it up!
(audience cheers)
Their movie is all about
courageous women who gamed
the commerce industry
with some quick thinking.
Now it's time to do some
quick thinking of our own,
hopefully, with a game we're calling,
"Quick Queenpins Categories".
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)
♪ Categories ♪
(Kelly laughs)
Do y'all just drink a lot of wine
when you come up with these?
I love the stings. The
stings are my favorite.
We're all playing, so we
need a host, of course.
I might as well ask the Almighty.
God, are you available?
- [Announcer] I'm here, Kelly.
You caught me in the
middle of my naked yoga.
(audience applauds)
(Kelly laughs)
So just hold tight. Let me
open a window real quick.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh my God! TMI!
Could you help us with a game
and tell us how it works, please?
- [Announcer] Well, of course, girl!
Now, in this game, I'm
gonna name a category.
- He sounds just like him.
- [Announcer] Okay? Now I
will then tell you who starts.
That person will say an
item in the category,
and then hit their button.
- Right.
- [Announcer] Then the
person to their left will go.
They'll say an item, and so on,
until someone isn't quick enough
or repeats an item already said.
Now if that happens, you're
gonna hear this sound.
(buzzer)
- Oh! Uh-huh!
- [Announcer] Now, the two
people that did not miss
will get points, and
the person who misses,
will do the downward-facing
dog for eternity.
I'm just playing.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- [Announcer] Okay.
You ready?
Your first category is "Brands
of Cars", and Kirby, you up.
- Okay.
(thinking music)
Lamborghini.
(button dings)
- Mercedes.
- Lincoln.
(button dings)
- Ford.
- Buick.
(button dings)
- Dodge.
- Tesla.
(button dings)
- Ooh! Um, uh, um...
(audience laughs)
I was so impressed!
(Kelly laughs)
(buzzer)
(Kelly screams)
(audience cheers)
That's the time?
- [Announcer] Oh, that's unfortunate!
- Wait, I didn't know there was a time!
I had one!
- [Announcer] That's unfortunate.
- Ford!
I had one!
- [Announcer] Now, now, come on, my child.
- We get-
- [Announcer] Calm down.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience cheers)
- [Announcer] Okay. Now the
next one is a curve ball.
- Okay.
- [Announcer] Next category is
(Announcer chuckles)
brands of vodka.
- Ooh!
(audience cheers)
Okay.
- [Announcer] Okay.
Kirby, you first. This
one is worth three points.
- Okay.
- [Announcer] This a big one.
Brands of vodka. Kirby, take it away.
- Tito's.
(button dings)
- Grey Goose.
- The orange
(Kelly gasps)
flavored one. I don't drink!
(button dings)
(buzzer)
(Kelly yells)
(audience cheers)
- Oh, yes!
(Kirby laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh, wow!
- Okay, wait,
so she loses that.
So what's the score, what's the score?
- [Announcer] Well, it looks like,
if my calculations are correct,
it looks like Kirby is now in the lead
because that last one
(audience cheers)
was worth three points!
- [Kelly] Oh, the last one
- Oh, so we're upping the points?
Oh, this is hard.
- [Kirby] Keep your head,
keep your head!
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- [Announcer] And this is the last one.
- Woo!
- [Announcer] Now, this
one is worth five points.
- Okay.
- All right, girl.
Keep your head.
(Kelly exhales)
- [Announcer] So get ready now!
Keep your head.
- Okay.
- [Announcer] This one is
"Titles of Songs by Michael Jackson."
(audience exclaims)
- Oh, no!
- [Announcer] Okay. Kristen, shamone.
(audience laughs)
- Man in the Mirror.
(button dings)
- Thriller.
- Black and White.
(button dings)
- P.Y.T.
- Billie Jean.
(button dings)
- Thriller.
(audience exclaims)
- Oh, no! Oh, no!
- [Announcer] Nope, nope,
(buzzer)
nope, nope.
- [Kelly] Oh, no!
You said it twice.
(air horn honks)
- So then you win!
(Kirby yells)
(air horn honks)
(Kristen applauds)
- [Announcer] And it looks
like the winner is...
(audience cheers)
It is Kirby!
You've done it, girl!
- I think what we've learned here...
- [Kirby] Thank you!
- I think what we've learned here is,
I'm not the best listener.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)